so democratic senator amy klobuchar  recently tweeted um honoring the memory  of police officers who died  in the line of duty in 2021 and i think  that that's fine in principle what's  missing from the tweet is the context  that a ton of those deaths were from  covid  among members of law enforcement who  simply refused to get vaccinated many of  whom would have survived if they had  simply gotten vaccinated so on the one  hand it's absolutely fine to honor those  who were in dangerous situations  and were tragically killed in the line  of duty at the same time shouldn't we  acknowledge that a whole bunch of those  people just refused to get themselves  vaccinated